listen I think mr. speaker they have
until the house rises today to table a
motion of no confidence in the
government
Holden
and we can have that vote tomorrow or if
any of the other parties the smaller
parties fancy ago
they can take all that emotional boogity
the time the truth it's not just that
this Parliament is gridlocked paralyzed
and refusing to deliver on the
priorities of the people it's not just
unable to move forward it's worse than
that mr. speaker out of sheer
selfishness and political cowardice
unwilling to move aside and did the
people are saying this is what they want
to do they're gonna cancel the first
referendum they're gonna legislate for a
second referendum and Parliament will
promise that this time that's not the
lady opposite the Parliament all promise
that this time it really really will
respect that vote and they think that
the public will dapple vote to remain
and everybody will forget the last few
years
Mr Speaker I have to say I think that is
an extraordinary delusion and a fantasy
a fantasy even greater than the
Communist fantasies peddled by the
leader gone
I've order appeal to the house my scent
to have some regard to how our
proceedings are viewed by people
watching them in the country at large
the order Oh death let the remainder of
the statement be heard and grateful for
the Prime Minister's exhortation but I
don't require it I'm perfectly content
what I want to hear is the rest of the
statement and then questioning on it the
Prime Minister the two years they have
demanded an election for twice they have
voted against it
the leader of the Opposition changes his
mind so often I wonder whether he
supports an election today or whether
the Shadow Chancellor or the shadow
attorney-general have overruled him
again because they know that the voters
will judge their manifesto for what it
is more pointless delay is he going to
demand Patty's going to demand an
election and then vote against it I
think the people of this country have
had enough of it this Parliament must
either stand aside and let this
government get Rexach done or bring a
vote of confidence and finally face the
day of reckoning with the voters I
commend
[Applause]